eu sou arquiteto e urbanista informe
técnico em edificações no segundo grau
pelo ifmt
na minha época ainda era escola técnica
foi no ano de 98 99 e pelo que me lembro
essa foi uma das únicas decisões que eu
também por conta própria área que eu
queria atuar
foi nessa época também que eu decidi me
dedicar a um menino um pouco mais nova
do que eu sei que parece estranho mas a
minha vida se resume numa seqüência de
acontecimentos não planejados uma
espécie de de caos organizado
então arroz branco não passei a viagem
que deu errado não invada interrompido
tudo isso que me fez chegar aqui hoje
fazendo uma releitura as minhas escolhas
foram baseadas em não acontecimentos o
que e como fazer depende de coisas que
eu planejava e não davam certo e foi
assim essa seqüência de não
acontecimentos que eu conheci algo que
mudaria minha vida uma nova maneira de
ver e me ver no mundo jeito diferente de
estar e de ocupar o planeta
foi nessa época nesse período em que eu
decidi por minha conta sem planejamento
nenhum apenas decidir viver de um jeito
que causar menos impacto no ambiente
a gente quando fala em sustentabilidade
a primeira idéia que vem à cabeça é o
que será que eu posso fazer para
diminuir o impacto que o causa e eu tô
falando de impacto ambiental eo
independente da área de atuação
construção se a gente falar em
engenharia produção de alimentos a gente
fala em agricultura medicina a gente
fala em saúde enfim tudo tem a ver em
reduzir o impacto
tudo bem que pra nós a única coisa que a
gente quer quando busca viver
sustentavelmente é seja social ambiental
ou financeiramente falando é tentar
viver de uma maneira que a gente apenas
consiga garantir que a próxima geração
possa continuar fazendo o mesmo que nós
parece parece simples né
a minha história começou a mudar há dez
anos em 2008 eu estava noiva e há dois
meses do casamento minha noiva me disse
que não era hora
lembro de ter ficado muito mal sim mas
isso me proporcionou arriscar mais
também
eu saí fui abag inscrever num curso com
a criação de comunidades sustentáveis e
esse curso de uma duração de dez dias um
lugar totalmente diferente numa zona
rural no interior de goiás onde as
construções eram diferentes as pessoas
eram diferentes e de alguma maneira
aquele lugar não tinha nada de luxo mas
ao mesmo tempo tinha muito conforto
esses dias foi muito importante para mim
porque me fez fazer uma releitura da
minha vida então e eu não tinha muito do
que mergulhar não é naquela época eu
estava com 27 e 28 anos e eu tinha
prestado vestibular para engenharia não
havia passado passei com arquitetura no
meio do curso de arquitetura foi
convidado a ingressar no exército
o meu eu sempre quis entrar para o
náutico então eu falei não o exército
naquele mesmo período eu tinha um sonho
de ter uma casa própria financiada por
20 e 30 anos também que hoje eu acho
isso estranho mas de alguma maneira de
tentar me encaixar ali mais tarde eu
casei comprei um terreno em chapada dos
guimarães um com a minha esposa e
descobrimos que tínhamos caído no golpe
do mesmo terreno tinha dois ou três
donos enfim de alguma maneira tentar
realmente encaixar nesse mundo maluco
que nós criamos mas foi durante esses
dez dias
nesse curso que conheci uma metodologia
uma ferramenta diferente de como
desenhar o espaço uma maneira que a
gente conseguisse causar impacto
positivo
até então a pergunta era como diminuir o
impacto que a gente já usava ea partir
dessa metodologia desse conceito a
pergunta ganhou uma resposta ea gente
passou a desenhar espaços para causar
impacto positivo no meio
desenhar espaços para promover
biodiversidade e esse é o segredo da
sustentabilidade é tentar entender tudo
que nós fazemos independente do que for
com um grande ecossistema vivo e
produtivo
há depois disso eu tentei desenhar todos
os projetos que eu pegava tendo esse
conflito no parlamento é um modelo de
desenho voltado com uma cultura uma
cultura da permanência
eu estou falando de uma cultura estranha
né
pela cultura ela vem da união de duas
palavras cultura em permanência
ela nasceu na década de 70 na austrália
e é fundamentada levando em consideração
conhecimentos básicos como conhecimentos
milenares conhecimentos populares
fazendo o uso de recursos que a natureza
oferece pra gente como solo a terra o
fruto a água o vento sol tudo isso
alinhado aí sim novas tecnologias
algumas pessoas chamam isso de serviços
ecossistêmicos uma cultura mais do que
isso é uma metodologia para a criação de
um ambiente onde haja conexão com vários
elementos inseridos dentro de um sistema
que a sustentabilidade está não dá
independência desses elementos mas a
conexão que existe entre eles
quanto mais conexão entre esses
elementos mais inteligente e autonomia
do sistema
isso vale para qualquer coisa que a
gente faz as conexões devem ser baseadas
em pretty lisando de três princípios
básicos
cuidado com a terra cuidado com as
pessoas e partilha do excedente
são as três premissas básicas para fazer
um projeto um design é um desenho pela
cultura cultura então é isso essa
ferramenta essa metodologia alguns
chamam até de ciência e ela mostra como
um lugar qualquer lugar pode ser
produtivo estável mas sustentável também
se respeitarmos seus três princípios
básicos cuidado com a terra
cuidado com as pessoas e partilha do
excedente da cultura desde então passou
a fazer parte da minha vida não só com
profissão mas como o como visão de mundo
também em 2015
eu decidi ir ao berço da permacultura na
tasmânia na austrália uma cultura foi
criada lá como disse na década de 70 por
dois australianos e um óleo som e sua
aluna época desde o bem ea minha idéia
era conhecer o lugar onde pela cultura
nasceu mas também me preparar para ser
professor de permacultura aqui no brasil
então no dia 19 de fevereiro
eu viajei uma das mães pra variar
algumas coisas também não deram muito
certo não sei se todo mundo sabe que na
época não fazia ideia mas para entrar em
alguns países é necessária comprovação
de vacina contra a febre amarela
enfim não fazia ideia mesmo que isso era
necessário chegando na austrália ainda
no aeroporto uma policial me tira da
fila me leva uma sala de interrogatório
e me fala que encontraram uma faca na
minha mala e eu fui interrogado com
dezenas de perguntas com risco de ser
deportado mas nenhuma pergunta foi sobre
febre amarela e foi assim que eu cheguei
nos traz é engraçado mas na época foi
difícil
aconteceram tantas outras coisas ali mas
também possibilitará conhecer pessoas
incríveis que hoje são grandes amigos e
vão chegando na tasmânia que é uma ilha
australiana eu fiquei de voluntário em
troca de abrigo e comida no centro de
uma cultura e lá foi interessante porque
para todo lugar que eu olhava existe uma
técnica é de baixo impacto inserida
então placas fotovoltaicas sistema de
saneamento ecológico banheiro
compostável estufas com com frutas e
verduras que não eram da época e não
eram da região também
enfim mas o que mais impressionou até
porque conhecia outros lugares iguais
àquele é que de alguma forma as pessoas
fazem as mesmas coisas que a gente faz
aqui fora elas conversavam elas viam
brincavam trabalhavam elas utilizavam na
hora não entendi mas aquele lugar mim
piorou muito fiquei nesse espaço por
mais quatro dias depois fiquei em uma
fazenda uma famosa por uma cultura na
tasmânia uma fazenda de criação de
ovelhas e também era regido pelo mesmo
conceito
e lá eu pude desfrutar de conforto
segurança enfim tudo que nós entendemos
como necessidade
claro que na austrália a realidade é
outra mas é que às vezes nós pensamos
que para ser sustentável é preciso mudar
toda uma rotina e sustentável não é isso
ser sustentável criar conexão com as
coisas é tentar manter a velha rotina
com novos hábitos e de alguma forma
conectar se com elementos que fazem
parte do nosso dia a dia conectados com
a família logo cedo com os produtos que
você coloca na mesa no café da manhã com
a casa com um lugar que você vive não só
mora enfim nós produzimos existe
qualquer animal produz resíduos
a gente tem uma idéia as empresas hoje
já estão entendendo que as suas
embalagens sejam elas alumínio plástico
ou o corpo já não fazem mais parte do
produto que está sendo vendido tudo bem
que isso não tem muito a ver com conexão
mas a gente individualmente pode e deve
conectar se mais com as coisas
de alguma maneira a gente precisa fazer
com que a nossa rotina nos inspire todos
os dias nós acordamos todos os dias
tentando melhorar em algo então que tal
começar pelo café da manhã conversar
mais com nossos filhos colocar comidas
mais saudáveis na mesa se conectar com
que a gente come e com quem está à mesa
se conectar com o momento se conectarem
com o lugar você poder sair da sua
cozinha e no seu quintal buscar o seu
tempero ou o chá
isso sim a qualidade de vida o resto
somos nós que inventamos bom tudo isso
parece muito teórico né
eu quero apresentar para vocês uma
tecnologia social baseada nos princípios
da permacultura é a bacia de
evapotranspiração muita gente conhece
como força de bananeira é um sistema
natural para tratamento de esgoto
onde bactérias e consórcio de plantas
que gostam bastante água tem o poder de
tratar de projetos do banheiro do
chuveiro do vaso sanitário da cozinha da
área de serviço
esse sistema que ele é 100% isolado
então não tem risco de contaminação com
lençóis freáticos ou com o solo é um
ecossistema fechado dentro de uma caixa
tecnologias sociais iguais a essa são
capazes de resolver problemas que pra
gente no mundo como a gente vive hoje
parece impossível
bom pra fechar os dez anos os dez dias
de curso que eu fiz lá em 2008 se
transformaram em uma imersão de quatro
anos
e lá eu aprendi realmente o poder da
permacultura e desde então essa é essa
foi e é a minha especialização é através
de uma cultura que de lá pra cá conhecer
muitas pessoas alguns países tantas
outras culturas que já estão fazendo a
diferença e é essa a questão sabe quando
o que a gente vai começar a nos juntar
as pessoas que já estão fazendo algo
diferente
o bom dessa história dessas pessoas
nesses lugares que eu conheci veio a
vontade de transformar um espaço com
cuiabá um lugar para poder mostrar os
meus filhos filhos que ainda nem tenho o
que eu entendo sobre viver não só a
morar num lugar onde eu pudesse
construir algo bonito saudável agradável
mas sustentável também bom esse lugar
ele é conhecido como lacan elabora um
laboratório que promove experiências
para uma vida sustentável e lá empresas
escolas universidades crianças jovens
adultos pessoas conhece um pouquinho
mais nesse assunto que me fascina
esses dez anos muitas coisas aconteceram
a ponto de não poder mostrar tudo isso
para pessoas que amo muito
mas o que me deixa feliz é que outras
pessoas viram e poderão fazer parte
disso tudo eu sei que parece difícil
mudar a ganhar novos hábitos mas privar
nossos filhos de um futuro melhor
parece um preço alto demais e eu não
falo sobre oportunidade de 64 de mercado
ou frequentar boas escolas ou ter uma
profissão reconhecida mas de conexão com
as coisas de estar bem consigo mesmo de
saber o poder individual de cada um
isso é mais do que qualidade de vida
estou falando de felicidade de verdade o
que eu quero dizer que nem tudo que
planejei pra minha vida foi exatamente
como eu imaginava ou o deu tudo certo ou
não vai dar eu acho até eu embora daqui
mas uma coisa é certa a minha decisão em
assumir a responsabilidade pela minha
existência enquanto vivo da terra isso
não precisou de planejamento ou de
objetivos ou de indicadores ou de metas
ou seja lá o que for isso foi uma
decisão pessoal minha de de tentar viver
em harmonia com a natureza
nós somos natureza e quanto mais
próximos e conectadas a ela mas
estaremos perto da felicidade
vamos ser inteligentes obrigado
[Aplausos]